a Florida college student is in custody
after a security breach at a Florida
Airport 22 year-old Michelle Sanket is
charged with criminal attempt to steal a
plane yesterday at Orlando Melbourne
International Airport only the co poll
shows us how the potentially dangerous
situation was diffused by fast-acting
employees Toni good morning good morning
Sankat was a part-time student at
Florida Institute of Technology he was
studying aviation management now
according to the FAA he had received a
commercial pilot's license back in
January but besides being 22 and a
student he was not qualified to fly this
type of plane there obviously seem to be
some planning involved police in Florida
are trying to determine what 22 year old
Kneeshaw Sankat was planning to do after
he boarded a commercial airliner
undergoing maintenance early Thursday
morning if he was a student pilot from
the area he would be familiar with the
airfield
authorities say the student pilot drove
to the curb outside the airport around
2:00 a.m. and left his car running he
then hopped a barbed wire fence and
boarded an American Airlines plane
sitting near a hangar the individual was
confronted as soon as he was on the
aircraft the employee who was on that
aircraft actually took the appropriate
action and escorted him off of the
aircraft but after he was dragged from
the plane he broke free running back
toward the jet soon after police took
him into custody within two minutes of
creating a problem we stopped this guy
from getting in the air this is only the
latest security breach involving a
commercial airliner last month a luggage
handler died after taking control of an
empty jet at seattle-tacoma
International Airport he conducted a
number of dangerous maneuvers before
crashing sand cat from the republic of
trinidad and tobago was studying in
florida on a visa he was not armed at
the time but police searched his car for
explosives before towing it away we're
obviously going to review all all of our
security you can rest assured that we
believe that in this instance our
security worked just fine police say
they searched San cats home and
confiscated his electronics but at this
time authorities say there is no
evidence to indicate a connection to
terrorism biana Tony thank you